former Atlanta police officer now  charged with murder waived his first  court appearance today Garret Wolfe is  charged with shooting and killing  Rashard Brooks last week CBS News  cameras captured the former officer  Ralph arriving at Fulton County Jail  this morning Wolfe I should say Ralph is  being held without bond on several  charges including murder that man  officer Devon Brosnan also faces charges  in Ralph's death our bigger pardon in  Brooks his death he posted bond left  jail and spoke out for the first time  since the shooting I felt he was  friendly he was respectful  uh I respectful to him and I was really  just there to see what I could do if I  made sure that he was safe brosnan says  he looks forward to cooperating with any  investigators who want to have a  conversation about what happened that  night  the funeral for Rashard Brooks is  scheduled for next Tuesday